[Musique]
ils vont trouver leur critique wayne de
bonheur au bord de l'eau au milieu des
arts cette maison éclusière sera bientôt
celle de ghislaine et philippe wilson
ils vont habiter et pour la faire
pleinement vivre
ils vont même ouvrir un gîte pour
cyclistes ici l'objectif c'est de faire
un système comme de refuges de montagne
mais pour les cyclistes donc c'est à
dire un point un endroit où sur leur
parcours les cyclistes s'arrêter dormir
à l'abri à l'intérieur
avoir une cuisine commune où ils peuvent
se faire à manger le soir
et puis prendre une douche avoir des
sanitaires
et puis repartir après pour pour leur
balade quoi ce projet ghislain et
philippe n'aurais pas pu le monter sans
l'aide de la mairie
c'est elle qui a signé une convention
avec voies navigables de france
tous ont le même objectif sauver ce
patrimoine local avec la cuisine commune
on est très attaché aux maisons
éclusières parce que c'est l'histoire du
village et que ça nous faisait peine de
les voir fermé puisque est aujourd'hui
beaucoup sont fermés
ne sont plus habité et le projet de vnf
est tombé à pic pour pour aller avec les
attentions de la commune de développer
du tourisme achats signal
[Musique]
entre me gêne et saint jean de losne le
canal de bourgogne compte 222 maison
éclusière un tiers sont à l'abandon
illustration à saint-florentin avec
l'une de celle restée inhabitée trop
longtemps elle a été dégradée pillés et
même squatteurs c'est la maison qui date
[Musique]
18ème et 19ème siècles donc l'enjeu
l'enjeu de la conservation de ce
patrimoine c'est m des êtres humains à
l'intérieur pour pour les conserver
propriétaires des maisons vnf finance
les travaux à sa charge et accompagner
les porteurs de projets seule obligation
pour les nouveaux locataires ne pas en
faire une simple maison d'habitation
on attend les gens à des anglais qui
envisage devrait durer entre cinq et dix
maisons projet
domi péniches hôtels mais on
en maison éclusière touristiques
culturels ou même agricole toutes les
bonnes idées sont les bienvenues en vis
des activités d'hébergement touristique
parce qu'on est quand même dans une
région où l'hébergement et est une
problématique est donc passé offrir la
possibilité de dormir dans une maison
accusés on pense que c'est attractif il
ya déjà des projets qui ont démarré là
dessus et qui marche très bien à chasser
l'ancienne maison éclusière a été
réhabilité pour former un ensemble
d'habitations solide
c'est à ce jour l'une des plus belles
réussites sur le canal de bourgogne